ich frage mich ob das die Lösung für das
Problem der Aborigines wäre man sollte
die schlimmsten Aboriginies in einem
Gebiet zusammenpferchen und ihnen eine
Chemikalie ins Wasser geben die sie
steril macht irgendwann würde keiner
mehr von ihnen übrig sein nun dies wurde
von keinem geringeren als einem der
engsten Freunde des Premierministers dem
westaustralischen bergbaumagnaten l
Hancock vorgeschlagen diejenigen die
sich in den zivilisierten Gebieten
eingelebt haben die ein gutes Leben
führen oder ein gutes Gehalt verdienen
die in die Gesellschaft
und mit umgehen könen die würde ich in
Ruhe lassen denjenigen die sich selbst
nicht gut tun und die Dinge nicht
akzeptieren die halbkaste und hier liegt
der größte Teil des Problems würde ich
das Wasser vollpumpen sass sie steril
sind und sich nicht mehr fortpflanzen
können das würde das Problem
lösen Sie mich bitte
nicht betäuben sie mich nicht bitte
wirst du dich
fügen ich werde
sterben wenn du noch einmal fluchst
werde ich dich wieder abfackeln
verstanden du hast die Message nicht
verstanden oder ich will zu meiner
Mutter kein Polizeibeamter wurde
belangt du bist sehr dumm
Mann dieser aborigin starb dre Stunden
später
kein Polizeibeamter wurde
[Musik]
belangt wir haben die Menschen in unsere
eigenen Konzentrationslager getrieben
tatsächlich haben wir die aborini von
der ersten Invasion bis heute ständig
auf einen untermenschlichen Status
reduziert die Politik sagt du bist ein
schwarzer
australischer du bist auf dieser
erwünscht das ist Sydney das Juwel
Australiens und des guten
Lebens ich bin auf dem Weg nach Palm
Beach um Diana Wards zu treffen die
Ferienhäuser mit Blick auf den Pazifik
oh das ist
beeindruckend ist es nicht wunderschön
und das alles ist Palm B ja das ist der
Pazifik von seiner besten
Seite die Leute kommen auf einen Drink
vorbei es gibt zwei Ebenen was fabelhaft
ist mit einer riesigen Terrasse wie hoch
ist die Miete zur
Zeit zur Weihnachtszeit etwa 30.000
australische Dollar pro Woche
das ist eine Menge Geld das ist es aber
es ist die Spitzenzeit wenn alle hier
sind dies ist das absolute Paradies
endlich habe ich es gefunden
ja sagen die Leute jemals zu ihnen 30
000 oder 4 000 pro Woche ist einfach zu
viel nein denn man zahlt für das was man
im Leben bekommt
ja hinter dieser millionenchweren
Aussicht liegt das andere Australien ein
geheimes Schlachtfeld auf dem die ersten
Bewohner Australiens gegen die
eindringenden Briten kämpften dies war
ihr Land dass sie tapfer und mit
Einfallsreichtum verteidigten aber sie
hatten keine Waffen und wurden
besiegt im Jahr
1838 so berichtete der Sydney Monitor
wurde beschlossen die gesamte schwarze
Rasse in diesem Viertel
auszurten und so leben viele der überle
das ist Eric eledra der im
Gesundheitszentrum derig Gemeinde am
bladw etwa 200 Meilen von Springs im
Northern Territory
arbeitet ich bin letztes Jahr hier
eingezogen leben in einem Haus
vielleicht 20 in einem Haus 15 in einem
anderen einige Leben
draußen haben sie eine Küche in ihrem
Haus nein keine Küche ich muss draußen
ein Feuer machen sie haben ein Feuer
dort und Holz kein Strom kein Strom
nein haben sie Wasser ja ich habe
draußen einen wasserharn und sie haben
keine Dusche oder SAS keine Dusche
es gibt also nur diesen einen
Wasserhahn um die Kinder zu waschen
müssen Sie sich also unter den
Wasserhahn stellen ja wir haben einen
Schlauch sie spritzen die Kinder ab ja
mit dem
Schlauch so sollte es doch nicht sein
oderin es ist ein reiches Land ja es ist
reich für einige man hat ein Recht auf
bestimmte Dinge sie zahlen Steuern ja
ich zahle meine Steuern aber ich lebe in
einem z sie hier leben sie mit ihrer
Familie ohne Küche mit einem wasserhan
draußen ohne
Strom dort drüben ist das was sie einen
regierungsgeschäftsführer
nennen ja er hat 18
Klimaanlagen ja er hätte mir eine
abgeben
[Musik]
sollen
das ist Kra die Hauptstadt von
Australien es ist sehr ruhig mit breiten
sauberen Straßen gepflegten Rasenflächen
ausgezeichneten Schulen und das ist das
australische
Parlament laut einer regierungsumfrage
ist dies einer der wohlhabendsten Orte
in einem der wohlhabendsten
Länder und das ist der Vorort Barten
benannt nach dem ersten Premierminister
Australiens Edmund Barten dessen
parlamentsgesetz von 1901 als white
Australia policy bet
die Doktrin der Gleichheit der Menschen
soarten sollte niemals für diejenigen
gelten die nicht britisch
waren und
weißhäutig Barton erwähnte mit keinem
Wort ein Volk das seit tausenden von
Jahren hier lebte die längste
menschliche Präsenz auf der Erde sie
wurden als kaum menschlich angesehen
unwürdig in der neuen vorstadtutopie
anerkannt zu
werden sind Australiens
Geheimnis dieser Film ist eine Reise in
dieses geheime Land mein Heimatland er
wird nicht nur die Einzigartigkeit der
ersten Australier
beschreiben sondern auch ihren Weg der
Tränen des Verrats und des Widerstands
von einer Utopie zur
anderen
wir sind etwa 200 Meilen von Springs
entfernt und fahren in das rote Herz
Australiens es ist eine Region die als
Utopia bekannt ist so nannten es die
ersten weißen hier die entweder einen
sehr ausgeprägten sinf Ironie hatten
oder von der Hitze wahnsinnig geworden
waren es hat seit Monaten nicht mehr
geregnet und es ist extrem trocken in
der Umfrage die ich zu Beginn des Films
erwähnte in der Barten und Canberra als
die privilegiertesten Orte Australiens
genannt
wurden wurde Utopia auch als der am
meisten benachteiligte Ort als der
Ärmste Ort Australiens
genannt es ist die Heimat der ersten
[Musik]
australiia
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe ein Treffen mit David Smith
arrangiert der die Klinik
init DAV und
seinamhe tun ihr Bestes um die Gemeinden
in den Weiten utopias und darüber hinaus
zu
versorgen der Wert ist gesunken
gut die Menschen leben hier weil dies
seit tausenden von Jahren ihre Heimat
ist ihr spirituelles und physisches
zuause und doch wird Ihnen die
grundlegende igert die das weiße
Australien als sein Recht betrachtet und
als selbstverständlich
ansieht wir kümmern uns um die
medizinische Grundversorgung obwohl wir
die Grundbedürfnisse der Menschen noch
gar nicht im Griff haben
Unterkunft sie sind hier draußen sie
haben keine öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel
wenn man also kein Auto hat ist man hier
draußen gefangen es gibt keinen
Busservice das Wesentliche ist dass wir
diesen Planeten zusammen teilen und ein
gleichberechtigtes Leben führen sollten
wenn diese Toiletten verstopft sind hat
das einen Masseneffekt durch die
Kontamination beim Händewaschen
verstehen sie und wen man kein und
L was ist
den ich zeige mal eben diese Toilette
hier okay ich zeige ihm was hier los ist
das ist eine überlaufoilette John mit
einer Menge verrostetem Blech darunter
das offensichtlich Schlangen und anderes
Ungeziefer
anlockt diese Toilette hier ist ein
Beispiel dafür was hier
passiert wir haben keine funktionierende
Toilette sollte meinen es gäbe hier ein
Waschbecken damit sich die Kinder die
Hände waschen
können einen Spiegel damit sie ihre
Augen untersuchen
können wir haben ständige Probleme
Kreuzkontamination durch
Gastroenteritis oh es gibt so viele
Dinge die dadurch entstehen können wo
soll ich
aufhören sie wissen dass ich diese
Probleme verdichten ganz zu schweigen
von den diabetischen und chronischen
Krankheiten
es gibt ein großes Problem mit Diabetes
es gibt ein großes Problem mit Nieren
und
coronaerkrankungen was wir aber noch
nicht in Angriff genommen haben sind die
Auswirkungen von minderwertigem Wohnraum
schlechter Instandhaltung und sanitären
Problemen auf das Leben der
Aboriginies all das muss nun es muss
abgerissen und neu gebaut werden ja eine
Renovierung würde nichts bringen nein
sind hier viele kakaken
ja erstor kurzem gesprüht habe ich
musste sie ihnen aus den Ohren holen sie
sind in ihre Ohren gekrabbelt und ich
habe sie anderen Gesundheitshelfern
gezeigt die haben mir nicht geglaubt ich
sagte das müsst ihr euch ansehen mit
einem ohrenspiegel dann seht ihr eine
Kakalake die sich mit ihren Beinen in
einem Ohr zusammengerollt hat bei
Erwachsenen und auch bei Kindern im
Gehörgang ich weiß dass sie da sind also
kann mir keiner erzählen dass es keine
Kakalaken gibt und es kein Problem
gibt apropos Ohren haben die Kinder auch
Entzündungen verstopfte Ohren
mittelohrantzündungen sind bei indigenen
Völkern ein wachsendes
Problem was sind die
Auswirkungen nun beim Lernprozess
verzögertes lernen weil sie nicht
richtig hören sie können die Lehrer
nicht hören
genau wir werden eine Menge Probleme
bekommen es gibt
Atemwegserkrankungen Kreuzkontamination
Durchfall
gastroenterittis wie wirkt sich das
besonders auf die kleinen Kinder aus nun
der
Wasserhaushalt sie verlieren 10% ihrer
Körperflüssigkeit und wir haben einige
ernsthafte
Probleme diese Bedingungen haben eine
verblüffende Ähnlichkeit mit Gemeinden
die ich vor 28 Jahren gefilmt
habe dies ist altes Filmmaterial aber es
könnte heute sein im ganzen abgelegenen
schwarzen australienint sich wenig
verändert zu haben dieselben Hütten
derselbe Mangel an grundlegenden
Dienstleistungen dieselben Krankheiten
wie das Trachom das zur Erblindung führt
und völlig vermeidbar
ist ich kann nicht glauben dass ich mich
in einem der reichsten Länder der Welt
befinde und es hier Menschen gibt
aborigin Gemeinschaften die unter
wirklich fast unmenschlichen Bedingungen
leben die Aboriginis werden häufig für
ihre Armut verantwortlich gemacht
während die Australier so tun als ob die
Regierungen versucht hätten in diese
unnachgiebigen Gemeinschaften zu
investieren und nie etwas erreicht
hätten ist die Wahrheit eine ganz andere
die Regierungen investieren nicht in
abgelegene aborigin Gemeinden weil sie
wissen dass sie sonst nicht mehr lange
an der Macht
wären ich finde es ziemlich schockierend
dass es in einem der reichsten Länder
der Welt ein solches Ausmaß an Armut und
einen solchen Mangel an Grundausstattung
geben kann
Australien könnte die Probleme leicht
lösen in Utopia wo wir sind in den
Homelands Leben nur 1400
Menschen nimmt man die aborigin
Gemeinschaft in den northern territories
als Ganzes so sind es nicht mehr als
000 Menschen wenn man also behauptet
dass wir dieses Problem nach Jahrzehnten
in einem Land dem es absolut nicht an
Ressourcen mangelt nicht lösen können
heißt das dass das Problem ganz woanders
liegt
Herr snoden sie sind seit 23 Jahren also
fast ein viertel Jahrhundert
Parlamentsabgeordneter für das Northern
Territory ein Drittel der Bevölkerung
des territories sind
aborigin warum gibt es nach all diesen
Jahren immer noch eine unveränderte
schockierende Armut wohin man auch
schaut es ist diese Frage kurz zu
beantworten es gibt eine Kombination von
Problemen eines davon sind einige
Altlasten die sich um eine sehr
schlechte Regierungspolitik seit
mindestens 50 Jahren
drehen ich mache schon soange Filme über
die australischen Ureinwohner wie sie
Politiker
sind und noch einmal so schockiert zu
sein ist eine ziemliche
Erfahrung dieute im lau der erzählt
haben sind eine Reihe von Ausreden im
Zusammenhang mit der Gesundheit für die
ich verantwortlich bin und die ich nun
schon seit einigen Jahren verantworte
haben wir bedeutende Maßnahmen ergriffen
die viele dieser Probleme angehen wir
haben eine sehr gute Politik die sich
mit dem Umgang mit chronischen
Krankheiten befasst diese Maßnahmen
wurden von dieser Regierung 2007
eingeführt und sie machen einen
signifikanten
Unterschied für einen aborigin der in
der Nacht in der ich in seiner Gemeinde
war starb gab es keinen signifikanten
Unterschied am nächsten Morgen waren
seine Familie und seine kleine
Blechhütte verschwunden wenn ein
aborigini stirbt stirbt auch sein
Zuhause in der Nacht in der ich dort war
starb ein Mann namens Mr Davy im Alter
von 47 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt in
seiner Hütte etwa 20 m von der Klinik
entfernt sie konnten ihn nicht mehr
retten mit all der Ausrüstung und dem
Fachwissen das sie haben und mir wurde
klar gemacht dass sie ihn nicht retten
konnten weil dieser Mann wahrscheinlich
als Kind an einer rumatischen
Herzkrankheit LT die dort die höchste
gemeldete Rate der Welt
hat deshalb investieren wir in die
medizinische Grundversorgung um
sicherzustellen dass die Kinder die
nächste Generation nicht die Probleme
ihrer Väter haben genau das tun wir und
ich bin stolz
darauf nun ich bin froh dass sie stolz
sind ich konnte nur keine Beweise für
irgendetwas in diesen Gemeinden sehen
haben sie mit den Ärzten gesprochen
rufen Sie die Ärzte an ja ich habe mit
den Ärzten gesprochen ich habe mit einem
Arzt gesprochen eine Ärztin ich habe
nicht damit gerechnet dass sie so etwas
sagen würde sie verglich die Bedingungen
mit dem dickenschen England des 19
Jahrhunderts sie sagte dass es damals
rumatische Herzkrankheiten gab ich
sprach mit einem anderen Arzt der mich
daran erinnerte dass Australien auf
einer schandliste der Vereinten Nationen
steht weil es das Trachom nicht besiegt
hat das sogar arme Länder wie Sri Lanka
besiegt haben und hat sie ihnen von den
Investitionen erzählt die wir gerade in
die Trachom Bekämpfung stecken ich bin
nicht stolz auf die Vergangenheit ganz
bestimmt nicht was ist mit der Gegenwart
ich bin stolz stolz auf die Gegenwart
auf die Tatsache wie kann ein Australier
in diese Gemeinden gehen und sagen er
sei stolz lassen Sie mich ausreden ich
bin stolz auf die Antwort die diese
Regierung auf die sehr schlechten
Umstände für die
gegeben hat nicht nur dort sondern auch
in anderen Gemeinden und ich will von
ihnen nicht hören dass wir nicht
entschlossen sind diese Änderungen
vorzunehmen und ich will von ihnen nicht
hören dass wir diese Mittel nicht
investieren was wissen Sie denn schon
über
mich ich stelle diese Fragen aus zwei
Gründen erstens sind sie der Minister
für die Gesundheit der
Ureinwohner und zweitens vertreten sie
seit 23 Jahren einige der ärmsten und
kränksten Menschen in
Australien warum haben sie das nicht in
Ordnung gebracht was für eine dumme
Frage was für eine dumme Frage was für
eine kindische Frage fast ein Drittel
der aberoriginies stirbt vor dem 45
lebensjahr manchmal in meinen dunkleren
Momenten denke ich dass die Lösung des
Problems der indigenen Entwicklung in
Australien die Kapazitäten Australiens
übersteigt und dass wir tatsächlich
Hilfe aus dem Ausland brauchen um dieses
Problem anzu
gehen wir brauchen Leute von außerhalb
Australiens die uns sagen wie wir mit
diesem Problem umgehen
sollen es ist hier so politisiert und
bitter geworden dass wir einfach nicht
mehr vernünftig damit umgehen
[Musik]
können
wenn man das australische Kriegsdenkmal
inra betritt werden aborigin neben
wilden Tieren Reptilien und Vögeln
dargestellt in einem Land in dem es
Denkmäler zum Gedenken an fremde Kriege
gibt steht kein einziges für diejenigen
die im Widerstand gegen die Invasion in
ihrem eigenen Land Australien kämpften
und
stabben gibt es im Museum irgendeine
Erinnerung an die grenzkriege an die
Kriege die gegen die Invasion geführt
wurden nein
warum ich weiß es nicht das war ein
großer Krieg nicht W ich weiß es
nicht wenn ich ihnen zuhöre bin ich
überrascht dass sie einen so
interessanten und aufgeklärten Blick auf
so viele Kriege haben aber kein solches
gedenken ich habe mit indigenen Soldaten
gedient es sind wunderbare Menschen ich
habe große Bewunderung für das was sie
getan haben und ich weiß wie sie
gelitten haben ich weiß wirklich nicht
warum wir uns nicht mit dieser
Geschichte auseinandersetzen vielleicht
sind wir nicht übermäßig stolz darauf
danke die Behörden in Australien sind so
empfindlich gegenüber dieser Wahrheit
dass man mir keine Erlaubnis gab an
diesem großen öffentlichen Ort zu filmen
also musste ich mit einer Kamera Tourist
spielen
meine erste Begegnung mit aberorigin war
hier in
Laus mit Blick auf die Botany Bay wo
Captain Cook landete ich war 11 Jahre
alt und es war ein Abenteuer auf den
Sanddünen zu sitzen und die Menschen zu
beobachten die in Hütten lebten und von
denen man annahm dass sie auserben
würden die Aboriginies wurden bei der
Volkszählung nicht gezählt im Gegensatz
zu den Schafen ein Schulbuch erklärte
warum wir sind zivilisiert und sie sind
es nicht diese Fernsehdokumentation aus
dem Jahr
1962 fängt die damalige Stimmung ein als
ob die abiginis gar keine Australier
werden eine Einstellung die sich kaum
geändert zu haben scheint betrachten Sie
sich selbst als dunkel und ihr Volk als
dunkles
Volk oh ja mein Vater war in Vollblut
und meine Mutter ist hell ich komme nach
meiner Mutter aber ich ordne mich nicht
besser oder schlechter ein als andere
ich sehe mich auf der gleichen Stufe wie
alle
anderen was glauben Sie warum sie so
leben na ja sehen Sie diese Wohnung hier
die ist nicht in Ordnung die Leute
zahlen hier Miete aber die Wohnungen
entsprechen nicht dem Standard viele von
ihnen könnten als Australier durchgehen
aber nur wenige wollen über ihre
Enttäuschung sprechen haben Sie sich
jemals selbst in dieser Sache engagiert
ja früher vor Jahren um ich habe für die
Kinderzulage
gekämpft ich bin gegen die Art und Weise
wie meine Leute diskriminiert werden sie
unterdrücken uns sie versuchen gar nicht
uns aufzurichten sie vergessen dass wir
Menschen
sind die Verunglimpfung ihrer
Menschlichkeit war Teil einer
ideologischen Kampagne die als history
wars bekannt
wurde nach der Wahl des konservativen
John Howard in den 90er Jahren hauptete
eine Gruppe von Akademikern und
Kommentatoren es gäbe keine Invasion in
Australien keine Massaker keinen
[Musik]
Völkermord die Ankunft der Briten war
ein Festtag für den die Ureinwohner
dankbar sein
sollten Sie und ihre Kultur waren so gut
wie obsolet ihre Geschichte
wertlos diese Leugnung des Völkermordes
war die Propaganda des Imperiums das
einmal mehr versuchte den Diebstahl von
Land und die Vertreibung seiner
Bevölkerung zu
rechtfertigen heute ist Australia Day
2013 anem die Gründung Australiens als
Strafkolonie im Jahr
1788 gefeiert wird die Sträflinge waren
die armen Briten und
Iren für die Aborigines ist dies der Tag
des Überlebens ein Tag der
Trauer was ist der Australia Day für Sie
einfach ein großes Fest unser ganzes
Land kommt zusammen und feiert glauben
Sie dass die ersten Australier eine
Rolle beim Australia Day spielen viele
von ihnen fühlen sich dadurch eher
beleidigt wirklich warum weil das der
Tag ist an dem wir vor 225 Jahren ihr
Land erobert haben ach so ja wir denken
auch an sie deshalb feiern wir ja auch
alle
glauben Sie dass Sie einen besonderen
Platz haben weil es Jahrtausende lang
ihr Land war sie könnten ihren
besonderen Platz haben aber jetzt ist es
der Platz von allen
aha sie leben immer noch in sehr armen
Verhältnissen nun ich schätze das ist
ihre Schuld
oder wenn sie auch ein Teil unserer
Gesellschaft sind müssen sie das gleiche
tun wie wir und versuchen zu helfen wo
sie können Arbeit zu bekommen oder nicht
um einer von uns zu sein ich weiß dass
es schwer für sie ist weil niemand sie
einstellen
will sie sagen dass es ihr Land ist wenn
Sie einer von uns sagen die ersten
Australier würden sagen dass es eher
umgekehrt
ist ja von ihrem Standpunkt aus ihnen
gehört das Land sie sind die
ursprünglichen Besitzer wir sind mit
unserer Flagge hierher gekommen und
haben gesagt das gehört uns ich weiß das
macht es schwer aber in der Geschichte
ist das immer so gewesen ja das ist
immer passiert W kommt nimmt von den
ursprünglichen ich kenne das aus den
Medien dass die betrunken sind oder
nicht mehr aufstehen können und sich
nicht mehr helfen
wollen das ist auch nicht gut
oder man muss versuchen Sie nüchtern zu
machen und ihnen sagen dass sie eine
Zukunft haben
können warum leben sie immer noch unter
so schockierenden Bedingungen nun ich
glaube das ist was Sie wollen ihnen wird
viel angeboten aber es ist das was Sie
wollen man bietet Ihnen viel an
ich war schon in Zentralaustralien und
so weiter ich glaube sie wollen einfach
so
leben sie mögen es so zu leben unter
sich
ja was ist mit den Menschen deren Land
es ursprünglich war die haben heute
nicht viel zu feiern oder doch das haben
sie warum wenn du in dieses Land kommst
bist du ein Teil dieses Landes sie sind
nicht in dieses Land gekommen sie waren
von Anfang an hier von Anfang an sie
hatten es schon seit tausenden von
Jahren wir sind alle Australier jeder
der in dieses Land kommt ist Australier
warum glauben Sie empfinden sie den
heutigen Tag als Trauertag als
anstößigen Tag weil er die Einnahme
ihres Landes feiert ich glaube nicht
dass das eine Beleidigung ist wir sind
alle Australier jeder einzelne Mensch
der hier an mir vorbeigeht jeder sie
sind Australier es spielt keine Rolle ob
sie schwarz weiß gelb blau grün was auch
immer sind sie sind Australier wir
alle seid ihr Australier nein nicht
irisch was glauben Sie was die ersten
Australier heute denen sie haben nicht
viel zu feiern oder die
Abig
inwiefern nun vor 225 Jahren wurde ihnen
ihr Land
weggenommen ja
Tschüss du redest nur scheiße
man die Tatsache bleibt dass wir dieses
Land nie verlassen
haben wir haben niemals irgendeinen Teil
unseres Landes
abgetreten oder es an ausländische
Siedler übergeben die Australier
sind das haben wir nie getan keines
unserer Völker hat jemals zugestimmt und
gesagt ihr könnt mein Land haben aber im
Gegenzug möchte ich ein paar
Sozialleistungen unser Volk hat nie von
einer solchen Transaktion
gewusst was mich erstaunt ist dass es
keinen Hass gibt den das ist unter unser
würde Menschen zu
hassen das machen wir nicht wir haben
diese Wut
nicht aber wir alten Menschen müssen
anfangen darüber nachzudenken wie wir
das Unrecht wieder gut machen können das
schreckliche Unrecht das uns und den
unsrigen immer noch
[Musik]
wiederfährt derü nimmt die schmalste
Brücke nach Perth während unten bei
applecoss die Bote an ihrem Liegeplatz
liegen das war die offizielle Vision der
60er Jahre von einem Vorstand Utopia in
Australiens größtem und reichstem
Bundesland aber sie beruhte auf der
Auslöschung einer ganzen menschlichen
Gemeinschaft was für ein schönes
Leben ein Tag am Strand am offenen me
ich bin auf dem Weg von Perth nach
rotnest Island Touristen nennen die
Insel rotto seit
1838 war sie ein brutales Gefängnis sie
soll so berüchtigt sein wie Robin Island
in Südafrika
bei mir sind Mary Anne may und no nen
zwei Mitglieder der indigenen nung
Nation sie kennen die Wahrheit über
diese Insel Als ich Mary Ann bat mich zu
begleiten hatte sie Angst bis no ihr
anbot sie vor dem Gefühl des Grauens und
der Ungerechtigkeit zu schützen das uns
erwartete
rodn Island war eines der am stärksten
isolierten Konzentrationslager des
britischen
Empire Teil einer völkermörderischen
Geschichte die im weißen Australien kaum
wahrgenommen
wird am Strand führt no eine Zeremonie
durch die uns alle schützen
soll
also du nimmst ein bisschen
Sand wird Naga also dein Körpergeruch
auf dem Sand
sein und wenn du ihn rauswirfst dann
weiß der Geist dass du hier
bist hier habe ich gerade das hier
entdeckt das
ist naiverweise habe ich eine
Beschreibung im historischen Teil
erwartet nicht über den Horror aber
vielleicht eine entschärfte Version über
das Konzentrationslager das hier
war aber da ist
nichts historisches R hier ist
es genieen sie das einzigar wer
von harmis Umgebung der rotn Lodge
tägliche feren und organisierte Flüge
können sie nur 30 Minuten in dieses
Paradies bringen dies war ein Gefängnis
bekannt als the quad tausende von
aborigin Männern und Jungen wurden hier
eingekerkert viele von ihnen gefoltert
und
getötet heute ist es ein Hotel mit einem
luxusbar
Australien muss das einzige Land sein
das aus einem Ort des Gemetzels ein
Touristenhotel
macht mir fällt kein anderes Land ein wo
es eine ähnliche Geschichte
gab aber das hier ist schockierend
oder ist so
entwürdigend wir fühlen uns so so
traumatisiert von all dem
und stell dir
vor sieben Menschen die hier leben die
in eine Zelle gepferchtt
sind es gab hier drei
Zellen unter welchen Bedingungen haben
sie hier
gelebt die Bedingungen unter denen sie
anfangs lebten als das Lager gebaut
wurde sie hatten nur einen
Lüftungsschacht über der Tür
das war alles und es wird hier wirklich
kalt und wirklich heiß dies ist
offensichtlich ein Familienzimmer hier
kommen die Kinder hin sie haben
doppelken die Eltern
hier und weißt du dieser Raum in dem wir
sind besteht eigentlich aus drei
Zellen in jedem Raum hier gibt es drei
davon und in jeder Zelle starben 17
Menschen
17 Menschen auf dieser Fläche von der
Wand dort drüben bis dort sind 51
Menschen
gestorben und dafür bezahlen die Leute
jetzt 240 pro Nacht ja so viel kostet
das wir haben das Zimmer gemietet um
dieses Interview zu machen 240$
unglaublich und sie haben keine Ahnung
was hier drin passiert
ist keiner sagt es Ihnen keiner lässt es
sie wissen und ich sage euch was wenn
ich an eurer Stelle wäre würde ich
wissen wollen was in dem Zimmer passiert
ist ind dem ich
schlafe direkt vor diesem Fenster dieser
Tür haben sie einen galden
gebaut sie hängten dort einen gascoin
Mann auf und die anderen Häftlinge die
mit ihm hierher kamen hatten noch nie
jemanden hängen sehen sie mussten sich
auf beiden Seiten des geigens
aufstellen die Gefangenen den Galgen
gebaut der hier stand und sie sahen zu
wie dieser Mann gehängt wurde sie waren
fassungslos und haben tagelang
getrauert und nichts
gegessen das hat sich genauso ausgewirkt
wie das was hier drin passiert ist und
diese Leute die hierher kommmen und hier
bleiben das ist es was die aborinis in
Australien erleiden müssen dem
glücklichen Land
ich meine Glück für
wen sicherlich nicht für uns wir sind
Flüchtling in unserem eigenen
Land neben dem Hotel befindet sich eines
der größten Massengräber Australiens
über 300.000 aborigin Gefangene sind
hier begraben bis vor ein paar Jahren
gab es kein Schild das darauf hinwies
dass dies heiliger Boden
ist
was früher die Leichenhalle war ist
heute die
Hotelküche der Manager des Hotels
erzählte mir dass es langfristige Pläne
gibt das Quad Gefängnis in eine
Gedenkstätte
umzuwandeln man sieht die
begräbnisstätdte und da ist überhaupt
kein Respekt vor der Geschichte unseres
Volkes all diese nicht gekennzeichneten
Gräber mit einem Schild das über den Ort
spricht und dann verläuft eine Straße
mittendurch wo man mit dem Auto
und die LE können einfach hindurchlaufen
und den Ort entweihen wo die Überreste
unserer Vorfahren
liegen rn Island ist nicht die
Vergangenheit Westaustralien ist ein
Staat der Gefangenschaft für schwarze
Australia am Australia Day
2008 Star
ein ein schrecklichen to er me
Transporter in glühender Hitze gefahren
wurde die Temperatur in der mobilen
Zelle erreichte 56° Celsus der
Gerichtsmediziner bezeichnete das als
eine Schande der Leiter der
Staatsanwaltschaft brauchte 2 Jahre
bevor er beschloss nichts zu unternehmen
schließlich wurden die Fahrer des
Lieferwagens ihre Arbeitgeber und die
gefängnisdirektion wegen Verstoßes gegen
die Gesundheits und
Sicherheitsvorschriften zu einer
Geldstrafe verurteil
ein aborig namens Mr W erlitt einen
wirklich schrecklichen
Tod der Gerichtsmediziner sagte er sei
regelrecht zu Tode gekocht
worden er sagte auch dass ihr
Ministerium als sie Ministerin waren für
seinen Tod mitverantwortlich
war ich habe auf jeden Fall über einen
Rücktritt nachgedacht denn was bringt es
im Parlament zu sein W man die Dinge
nicht zum Besseren verändern
kann nun der Rechtsdienst der
Aboriginies hat sie als Ministerin
routinemäßig gewarnt sie konnten also
nicht sagen sie hätten es nicht
gewusst nein ich wusste es und ich kann
mich daran erinnern dass ich einen
langen Brief an den aborigin
Rechtsdienst schrieb ich tat das auf der
Grundlage dass man mir versicherte
danach zu
bessern das war ein besonders grausamer
Tod ein Mann wurde zu Tode gekocht
er war so heiß dass er sich schreckliche
Verbrennungen am ganzen Körper zuzog und
er starb wer trägt die letzte
Verantwortung letztendlich haben Sie
Recht die Verantwortung liegt bei mir
das gesamte Justizsystem ist bis zu
einem gewissen Grad schuldig wie ich
schon sagte weiche ich meine Rolle nicht
aus weil ich mich in gewisser Weise
persönlich verantwortlich
fühle sie waren
verantwortlich ja absolut und das ist
etwas D ich bis zu meinem Tod sehr
bedauern
werde warum sind sie nicht
zurückgetreten ich habe es in Erwägung
gezogen was ist dann
passiert ich dachte na ja ich wollte
sehen ob ich sie wissen schon alles tun
kann um das Problem zu
lösen was haben sie dafür
getan was ich getan habe war wir hatten
z.B andere Transportmittel bessere
Fahrzeuge bestellt
es gibt Dinge wie diese die geändert
werden
müssen aber sowas passiert weißen
Menschen nicht oder nein natürlich
nicht wann ist das letzte Mal ein
Minister in Australien zurückgetreten
und hat gesagt dass wir diese Art von
abscheulichem Rassismus nicht hinnehmen
können es scheint dass wir auf den
nächsten Fall
warten mein Personal musste zu einem
kulturellen
sensibilitätstraining
die Mitarbeiter in meinem Büro sodass
ich dann die zuständige Behörde
kontaktieren konnte in der Hoffnung dass
sie dann einige dieser grundlegenden
Fragen
verstehen was ist kulturelle
sensibilitätstraining nun über die
Kultur der Aboriginies und was die
Probleme aus der Sicht der
strafvollzugsdienste
sind ich habe meine Mitarbeiter von
denen ich dachte dass sie in meinem
Ministerbüro einen guten Job machen
dieser Schulung unterzogen damit ich die
leitenden Angestellten des Ministeriums
dazu bringen könnte einige grundlegende
Fakten über die Kultur der aborigin zu
lernen sie wussten also nichts über die
Geschichte sie wussten nicht dass es in
diesem Land Massaker gab sie wussten
nicht dass Menschen auf eine Art
Teufelsinsel geschickt worden
waren sicherlich wussten das einige von
ihnen es gibt sehr wohlmeinende Leute
die das wissen aber einige der leitenden
Angestellten einmal wurde eine
Mitarbeiterin als sie hier in die
Abteilung kam in einem Interview in der
abteilungszeitschrift gefragt wie sie
mit der Kultur der aberiginies in
Berührung gekommen sei sie sagte sie
stamme aus Bradford und habe mit vielen
Pakistanern zu tun gehabt daher verstehe
sie diese Probleme und wie hatte sie vor
mit den Aboriginies in Australien
umzugehen ich hatte keine Ahnung kurz
danach arrangierte ich die Schulung
sie haben das kulturelle
sensibilitätstraining
organisiert baut Westaustralien jetzt
mehr
Gefängnisse im Moment sind sie glaube
ich dabei sie zu stapeln wie man so
schön
sagt was soll das
heißen na ja das ist eine doppelte
Unterbringung es bedeutet buchstäblich
Menschen zu lagern sie und
stapeln das ist die Art und Weise wie
sie die Sklavenschiffe gefüllt
haben das ist es was sie tun sie lagern
und stapeln Sie haben gerade das 14
Gefängnis gebaut es wurde von vielen
Leuten gelobt es ist in Derby und ist
ein Gefängnis für
Aboriginis es ist also hauptsächlich für
Aboriginis nein nur Aboriginis von
weniger als 3% der Bevölkerung
heute gehören schwarze Australier zu den
am meisten Inhaftierten Menschen der
Welt diese ganze Vorstellung von einem
Staat der für Recht und Ordnung sorgt
wird immer mehr zu einem
zentaurenstat der sich um diejenigen
kümmert die sich den neoliberalen
globalen Werten
anpassen die sich nicht anpassen
inhaftiert und sehr hart
behandelt ich glaube was wir in
Australien sehen ist nicht nur eine
Bestrafung der Armen sondern auch eine
Bestrafung der indigenen
andersartigen das sind Menschen die
grundlegend andere Normen haben und sie
sind sehr anfällig dafür sich nicht an
die Normen des Staates von Recht und
Ordnung anzupassen der wiederum so
argumentieren einige ein direktes
Produkt des globalen Neoliberalismus
ist dieser Mann hatte kein Verbrechen
begangen er war betrunken und schwer
krank die Polizei nennt das
Schutzhaft mein wurde in gewsam genommen
ich glaube es war am 3 Januar wissen Sie
die Polizei kann Leute von der Straße
holen von denen sie glaubt dass sie
Schutz
brauchen sie haben ihn in Schutzhaft
genommen und die einzigen Leute vor
denen er Schutz brauchte waren
sie setz dich hin man setz dich hin
man sei nicht dumm man in Ordnung oder
wir bringen dich runter an die
Zelle
setz dich hin
Mann setz dich
Mann alles klar du bist sehr dumm Mann
okay nicht gerade ein glamuröser Job
dieser Mann ist 27 Jahre alt und stirbt
in seiner Zelle allein und
hilflos sein Name war Brisco er starb an
Vergiftung Erstickung und an seiner
Behandlung durch die
Polizei die seine Hilferufe
ignorierte der Gerichtsmediziner sagte
sie hätten ihm das Leben retten können
niemand wurde
ol er wurde zum Sterben zurückgelassen
während die Polizisten im Internet
surften hier bei uns im Northern
Territory war die inhaftierungsrate
sechsmal so hoch wie unter den schwarzen
während der letzten 10 Jahre der
aparthit in
Südafrika in Westaustralien ist sie
offenbar achtm so hoch glauben sie dass
Australien als aparidstaat betrachtet
werden
sollte ich glaube nicht dass es einen
großen Unterschied gibt abgesehen von
der Tatsache dass es nicht überall
Schilder gibt auf denen steht das
schwarze aus diesem Wasserhahn trinken
und weiße aus jenem allein in Springs
müsste man schon blind sein um keine
apaththeit zu sehen die Zahl der
Menschen die in Schutzhaft genommen
werden ist schwindelerregend und bei dem
jüngsten Todesfall in Springs kann ich
mich nicht an die Zahlen erinnern aber
selbst nach 25 Jahren im Northern
Territory war ich verblüfft dass
tatsächlich so viele Menschen in
Gewahrsam kommen der Beweis ist erbracht
alle unsere Gefängnisse vor allem im
Northern Territory sind zum bärsten voll
und das wird sich so schnell nicht
ändern wir müssen uns mit den zugrunde
liegenden Problemen befassen und wieder
fällt es mir leicht das zu sagen weil
ich die Antwort nicht kenne aber wir
haben darüber gesprochen den Menschen
eine gute Unterkunft zu geben eine gute
Ausbildung sich um die Gesundheit der
Menschen zu kümmern wie um die eigene
und die alle anderen in der
Gemeinschaft
1981 starb Eddie Murray in
Polizeigewahrsam in der Stadt WE war in
New South
Wales trotz der Beweise für Lügen und
Vertuschung durch die Polizei wurde
niemand strafrechtlich verfolgt eine
zweite Untersuchung ergab dass sein
Brustbein zertrümmert worden war mehr
als 25 Jahre lang habe ich die Kampagne
von edys Eltern Arthur und lila may für
Gerechtigkeit
verfolgt dieses Interview habe ich
1987 mit ihnen
aufgenommen wie ich ed kenne hätte er
sich nicht das Leben genommen ich glaube
er wurde von einem Polizeibeamten
getötet 2012 kehrten Arthur und ich nach
wew zurück wo seine Familie aufgewachsen
und ED getötet worden
war
das Leben und die außergewöhnlichen
Leistungen von Arthur Murray sind im
weißen Australien fast unbekannt Arthur
arbeitete als Hexler beim unkrautjäden
auf den Baumwollfeldern er bekam etwas
mehr als ein Dollar pro Stunde schwarzen
Australian einen Hungerlohn zu zahlen
hat im Land des Fair go eine lange
Geschichte es war auch hart weil es
Flugzeuge gab die über uns flogen wenn
wir arbeiteten mit Pestiziden wenn Sie
die baumwolleprü haben sprü wir mussten
unter diesen Bedingungen arbeiten bis
wir dem ein Ende
setzten und die baumwollarbeiter
streikten und hunderte von ihnen
marschierten durch die
Stadt wir wollten bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen bessere
Lebensbedingungen und höhere
Löhne ich sorgte dafür dass die aborigin
die Arbeit niederlegten und nicht auf
das Baumwollfeld
gingen
einig sie waren alle einverstanden wir
stellten die Arbeit ein und
demonstrierten die Lokalzeitung nannte
sie kommunistische Unruhestifter Arthur
war die beste Art von Ärger die
baumwollarbeiter errangen einen
historischen
Sieg wir haben eine dreifache Schlacht
gewonnen und diese drei waren höhere
Löhne
Lebensbedingungen euch wurde erlaubt
hier zu kämpfen hier zu kamppen unsere
Forderungen wurden also
erfüllt aber die Familie Murray zahlte
einen hohen Preis sie wurden von weißen
schikaniert und oft angegriffen was zum
gewaltsamen Tod von Eddie
führte die weißen hielten es nicht für
richtig dass wir hier
leben also kamen sie und schüchterten
uns ein und belästigten
uns mit welchen Gefühlen kommst du
zurück nach we
arur weißt du es
ist es ist schwer an diesen Ort
zurückzukehren es ist ein Gefühl einen
Jungen zu
verlieren weißt du Leute wie ich und
andere die für die Aboriginies gekämpft
haben für ihre Rechte und für bessere
Bedingungen wofür haben sie
gekämpft wir glauben dass es richtig war
das hat sich kein bisschen geändert und
ich bezweifle dass es sich ändern
wird das fragt man sich immer wieder man
stellt sich die Frage immer wieder
werden wir Gerechtigkeit erfahren wird
es Menschen geben die anerkennen dass
wir hier in diesem Land
existieren es gibt Regeln für die
weißen und es gibt Regeln für die
schwarzen so sehe ich das
ich meine die königliche Kommission hat
gesagt dass die Polizei Meineid
geleistet hat dass sie ihre
Aufzeichnungen gefälscht hat dass sie
gelogen
hat wie viele Strafverfolgungen gab es
null wie viele Empfehlungen hat die
königliche Kommission am Ende
ausgesprochen 339 Empfehlungen hat es
gegben aber es wurde
nichtsan eserben immer noch Menschen
inzesam und im
Gefängnis an dem Tag als sich die Treppe
durch die Eingangstür
hinaufging und man mich bat die Treppe
hochzukommen und man mir sagte dass er
tot sei konnte ich es nicht glauben ich
kann es immer noch nicht
glauben wie fühlst du dich nach all
diesen Jahren was wünscht du
dir einen Blick darauf wirft um zu sehen
ob wir einige Antworten von Ihnen
bekommen können was sie uns weggenommen
haben unseren
Sohn ich habe im Laufe der Jahre viel
gelitten weißt
du ich glaube nicht dass ich noch mehr
ertragen
kann wir brauchen Antworten
John
wann glaubst du werden sich die Dinge in
diesem Land
ändern wenn die Gerechtigkeit in diesem
Land
funktioniert lila ist 2004 gestorben und
kämpft immer noch für
Gerechtigkeit jedes mal wenn du hierher
kommmst bist du traurig und wütend oder
ja es ist beides Traurigkeit und auch
Wut weißt du es ist schwer darüber zu
sprechen aber ich muss meine Gefühle
ausdrücken über meinen Sohn den ich
geliebt habe und ich muss meine Wut
darüber ausdrücken wie er gestorben
ist unter diesen
Umständen und diese Wut ist immer noch
in
mir es ist fast unmöglich zu sagen dass
nicht umsonst gestorben
ist er hatte eine Kampagne im Namen so
vieler anderer
begonnen wie auch dein T-Shirt
zeigt es ist die Anerkennung dessen
durch das weiße
Australien
sie kann das weiße Australien von seiner
Rolle beim Tod junger Männer wie Ed
erlösen wenn das überhaupt möglich
ist
Anerkennung das bedeutet Gerechtigkeit
nicht
W sicher wäre das
Gerechtigkeit es passierte
1981 jetzt haben wir 2012 und wir warten
immer noch
daraues
sie ist noch nicht
gekommen das ist Lilas
Grab ja sie fühlte Johns enormen Schmerz
und Kummer und sie dachte dass wir
vielleicht eines Tages Gerechtigkeit
bekommen würden aber wir wurden
enttäuscht
dieil wurde im S gelassen wie alt wart
ihr als ihr beide euch kennengelernt
habt ich war 15 le war
17 sie ist z Jahre älter als ich wir
waren 46 47 Jahre
zusammen und hab zusammen Kinder
großgezogen
ja eine großartige Lady eine großartige
Frau ich kann nichts Besseres sagen als
dass sie eine elegante und liebenswerte
Frau
war Arthur may Einsatz für die
baumwollarbeiter ist Teil einer
verborgenen Geschichte des Widerstands
der aborigin
epische Siege von Viehzüchtern
Landarbeitern und ihren Familien
beendeten die Sklavenarbeit in
Australien in W Hill im Northern
Territory wurde ein historischer Streik
des gorinji Volkes zu einem Sammelruf
für Gerechtigkeit für alle schwarzen
Australier Bewegung dieser Streik war
der längste Streik in der Geschichte
Australiens a Jahre und sie wurden von
der Polizei bedroht und von anderen die
auf der Wache arbeiteten dagegen haben
sie sich gewehrt das ist eine der
historischsten Bewegungen in diesem
Land W Hill war die größte viefarm der
Welt im Besitz des britischen
Multimillionärs Lord
West
die Ureinwohner waren das Rückgrad der
Viehwirtschaft doch sie arbeiteten für
wenig oder gar kein Geld oder Rationen
1966 machten sich die Arbeiter und ihre
Familien unter der Führung von Vincent
lingiari auf den Weg ihren Widerstand
beschreibt der gewerkschaftsorganisator
Dexter
Daniels wir wollen das Geld jetzt sie
wollen das Geld jetzt ja wir haben zu
lange gewartet sie wollen also wirklich
das Gesetz brechen ja und sie haben alle
beriginies auf ihrer Seite ja im ganzen
Northern Territory
ja ich werde alles tun was ich kann auf
jede erdenkliche Weise ich werde sie auf
meine Seite
bringen ihr Streik war ein Sieg für den
Grundsatz des gleichen Lohns und
menschenwürdiger Arbeits und
Lebensbedingungen der Kampf um
Landrechte steht im Mittelpunkt des
anhaltenden Freiheitskampfes in
Australien schwarze Australier haben
eingeschränkte Landrechte und ein
ureinwohnertitelgesetz errungen das
jedoch oft den Institutionen der weißen
macht den Vorzug gibt was zu erbitterten
spaltungskämpfen um heiliges Land und
den darunterliegenden Reichtum
[Musik]
führt
das heilige Herz der australischen
Ureinwohner ist
Uluru wo Touristen für mehr als 2000 pro
Nacht das schöne Leben genießen können
ist es umweltbewusst und auerhalb der
sweite derut und der Slams der deren
Land dies
[Musik]
ist die Menschen in mutujulu sind die
Hüter des
Felsens ihre überfüllten Häuser sind
voller Asbest das Krebs
verursacht seit 2008 hat die Regierung
Imen
das ist das Haus meiner Tochter Mary sie
lebt hier mit ihrer Großfamilie und
mittlerweile leben 32 Menschen in diesem
einen Haus 32 Menschen die Gemeinde hat
das Haus dort beschlagnahmt weil das
Asbest komplett aufgeplatzt ist und
alles kam raus es in Zukunft
gesundheitliche Probleme verursachen
kann unter großem Druck oder weil
Menschen aus Abbruchhäusern in Häuser
wie dieses umziehen
mussten sie haben also ganz motjulu
überprüft die gesamte Community sie
haben in 70% der Gebäude Asbest gefunden
so wie hier gekennzeichnet und trotzdem
haben sie den Menschen erlaubt weiterhin
darin zu
wohnen ja denn offensichtlich haben wir
keinen anderen Ort zum Leben und meine
größte Sorge weil wir hier kleine Kinder
haben
[Musik]
im Moment sind wir in einer äußersten
Notlage man schläft eng beieinander so
wie wir es als Kinder getan haben da ist
das Badezimmer ja Badezimmer und die
Toilette hier leben so viele
Menschen ein asbesaus kann man nicht
renovieren es muss abgerissen
werden dort leben 20 Menschen in einem
Haus mit einer Toilette und jedes Mal
wenn mehr Leute zum Übernachten kommen
zu Überschwemmungen in der Kanalisation
im Hinterhof steht das Abwasser wir
reden hier also über Würmer manchmal
frage ich mich auch ob ich Menschen auf
Cholera testen sollte ich habe ein Auge
drauf hat dieses Haus überhaupt Geld von
der wohnungsbehörde erhalten für eine
Renovierung wir haben keinen Cent
bekommen um unsere Häuser zu reparieren
die Reparaturen die wir hier machen sind
wir gehen zur örtlichen müllddeponie und
recycelen was wir können so müssen wir
hier überleben
es gibt hier auch viele kleine Kinder
oder nun der Großteil des Haushalts
besteht aus
Grundschulkindern
Grundschulkinder daher wird es bei
dieser Art von Überbelegung zu
kreuzinfektionen kommen für die alle
Kinder anfällig
sind 70% Hörbehinderung bei den kleinen
und das ist nicht alles 70% 70%
Ohrenentzündung ja ja und sind sie
teilweise taub sie sind teilweise taub
ja sind sie meine Tochter hier der
dieses Haus gehört ist taub wie ironisch
dass meine Tochter ein
asbesthaus mit 32 Menschen darin
errichten muss Australia deshalb
sprechen wir von einer Verletzung der
Menschenrechte g ein
ber Maß von Unterernährung und Hunger
erwähnt
wurden oh absolut unterernährte Kinder
übergewichtige Menschen die immer noch
unterernährt sind weil sie sich
hauptsächlich von Mehl und Fleisch
ernähren was hier von der Verwaltung
subventioniert wird ein Teil des Geldes
das der Gemeinde durch das
Tourismusprojekt zufließt wird zur
Subventionierung der fleischkosten
verwendet damit die Menschen zwar genug
Eiweiß bekommen aber nicht genügend
Vitamine weil sie kein Obst und Gemüse
bekommen weil sie zu teuer
sind wie viele Menschen müssen in diesem
Bett schlafen also wenn man die Kinder
zusammenquetscht Kopf an Fuß Kopf an Fuß
wahrscheinlich so a oder neun a oder
neun Kinder in einem Bett und dann haben
wir noch einzelne Matratzen auf denen
etwa drei oder vier
schlafen aber ihr habt einen Bericht
nach dem anderen von der Regierung
erhalten der besagt dass die größte
einzelursache für Armut unter den
der
[Musik]
Wohnungsbau nach seiner Entschuldigung
versprach Kevin R tatsächlich ganze 700
Millionen Dollar für den Wohnungsbau
Häuser in indigenen Gemeinschaften wo
ist es
denn sie schickten neun brandneue
Fahrzeuge mit Leuten in diesen neuen
Fahrzeugen das sind die wohnungsleute
sie kamen und prüften die Gemeinschaft
aber nicht nur einmal sondern
sie
immer noch
so bei uns wohnen auch noch mehr
Leute draußen draußen hier
drin hier schläft also eine Familie ja
hier schläft eine
Familie ich habe manchmal das Gefühl
dass ich es mit ähnlichen Bedingungen zu
tun habe wie in der englischen
Arbeiterklasse in den 1870er oder 1780er
Jahren leen in einem Raum und einem
offenen Abwasserkanal im Haus Menschen
die mit schrecklichen
Infektionskrankheiten zu kämpfen hatten
die sie früh töteten und Suchtverhalten
aufgrund der Enteignung die die
englische Arbeiterklasse zu Beginn der
industriellen Revolution
durchmachte im Jahr 2007 erklärten
Premierminister John Howard und sein
Minister Mel BR den
ausnahmezustandhängten jed nur schwar
meine Damen und Herren Herr und ich
haben diese Pressekonferenz einberufen
um eine Reihe wichtiger Maßnahmen zur
Bewältigung dessen
anzukündigen was wir nun als nationale
Notfall bezeichnen können Missbrauch von
Kindern in indigenen Gemeinschaften im
Northern
Territory bekannt als die Intervention
deren Ziel so sagten sie darin bestand
aborig Kinder vor Pädophilen zu retten
aber es gab eine versteckte Absicht es
ist interventionistisch es verdrängt die
Rolle des Territoriums bis zu einem
gewissen Grad ich akzeptiere das aber
was ist wichtiger die
verfassungsrechtlichen Freiheiten oder
die Fürsorge und der Schutz kleiner
Kinder die Intervention wurde auf der
Grundlage einer sehr zynischen großen
Lüge eingeleitet einer bösartigen Lüge
die alle im nor territory verunglimpfte
weil der damalige Minister für indigene
Angelegenheiten
sagte Gemeinden die die Regierung
besetzen würde pädophilenringe gäbe eine
außergewöhnliche
pauschalbehauptung die Gesetzgebung die
die Intervention diese bundesstaatliche
Machtübernahme möglich machte erwähnt
Kinder nicht wirklich aber die
Propagandamaschinerie war von Anfang an
unerbittlich jeder in diesen Gemeinden
weiß wer die Pädophilen räe leitet sie
wissen wer den Sprit bringt sie wissen
wer das Gras verkauft man muss sie aus
der gemeinsch Hermen und sich mit ihnen
auseinandersetzen eine unglaublich
umfassende Behauptung wenn wir die
Kinder retten wollen brauchen wir keine
Empfehlungen mit den aborigin
Organisationen sprechen sie zu
konsultieren und die aborigin Familien
selbst fragen wie steht es um die Kinder
es wurden einfach Truppen
reingeschickt sie haben alle zu Tode
erschreckt das hat es wirklich getan die
Müter Kind würden ihnen weggenommen und
flüchteten jeder hat diese Gemeinschaft
verlassen die Armee kam also einfach mit
ihren Lastwagen an und schlug ihre Zelte
mitten in der Gemeinde auf ja hier genau
hier die australische Armee in einer
australischen aborigin Gemeinschaft ja
all diese Soldaten wir wurden
[Musik]
angegriffen zum ersten Mal im modernen
Australien wurde die Armee in schwarze
Gemeinden geschickt als sperspitze einer
Regierung die entschlossen war das Leben
der Menschen und ihr Land zu
kontrollieren Angst und Schock
überwältigten die Gemeinschaften
Menschen die sich weigerten die Pacht
ihres Landes abzugeben sollten
grundlegende Dienstleistungen wie
angemessener Wohnungsbau und sanitäre
Einrichtungen verweigert
werden ein staatliches
Beschäftigungsprogramm das Tausende in
abgelegenen Gebieten Beschäftigte wurde
so gut wie abgeschafft Leistungen und
Renten wurden eingeschränkt und die
Menschen konnten nur mit einer
speziellen basic Karte das Nötigste
kaufen nur schwarze Bürger wurden auf
diese Weise
behandelt da die Menschen kaum noch Geld
verdienen konnten wurde von Hungersnöten
berichtet der regierungseigene
prüaussch
derest die Rate der Selbstverletzungen
und Selbstmordversuche vervierfachte
sich den Grundstein für die Intervention
legte eine grelle Medienkampagne die von
einer landesweiten Fernsehsendung namens
leline angeführt
wurde
line behauptete dass ab Kinder Opfer von
Sexsklaverei sein die Vorwürfe des
Programms konzentrierten sich auf die
Gemeinde
mjulu ein Kronzeuge war dieser Mann
dessen Identität verschleiert wurde sie
nannten ihn einen ehemaligen
Jugendarbeiter die Leute die die
Kontrolle haben sind die Drogendealer
die
benzinwlords und die Pädophilen es gab
keine Sexsklaverei keine Benzin Warlords
keine
pädophilenringe bei dem anonymen Zeugen
handelte es sich tatsächlich um einen
hochrangigen Regierungsbeamten der in
mutujulu gearbeitet aber nie dort gelebt
hatte das leline Programm wurde vom
investigativen Journalisten Chris Graham
dem Gründer der National indigenous
times
aufgedeckt
im Jahr 2006 begann leline zu berichten
dass sexueller Missbrauch in aborigin
Gemeinschaften weit verbreitet
war und dass aborigini Männer
gewalttätig waren und Frauen und Kinder
in einem unglaublichen Ausmaß schlugen
und
misshandelten und es war dieser Stil
außergewöhnlicher
Sensationsberichterstattung der der
Regierung den Weg ebnete Maßnahmen
einzuführen die die Australier offen
gesagt noch nicht gesehen hatten
der anonyme Jugendarbeiter war
tatsächlich ein Regierungsbeamter namens
Gregory
Andrews und er behauptete er habe
tatsächlich 7 Monate dort gelebt er
hatte keine einzige Nacht dort gelebt er
hatte noch nie in seinem Leben in Module
übernachtet mehrere Leute haben mir von
Männern in der Region erzählt die in
andere Gemeinden gehen junge Mädchen
holen uns in ihre Gemeinde zurückbringen
und sie dort sechsklaven
halten das lustigste war Greg Andrews
oder diesen Mann mit Hut und Pullover zu
sehen von dem ich wusste dass es sein
Hut und sein Pullover waren und ihn zu
sehen wie er da saß und mit dieser
Roboterstimme über Dinge sprach die er
über diese Gemeinde wusste oder zu
wissen
behauptete und ich sitze da und sehe ihn
und denke ist das Greg und er war es und
wer war ihrer Meinung nach Greg
Gre Andrews war mein Chef im Office of
indigenous policy coordination er war
stellvertretender Sekretär und
Abteilungsleiter er war also ein
hochrangiger Regierungsbeamter ja ja er
hat alle möglichen bizarren Behauptungen
aufgestellt er behauptete er wisse oder
habe davon gehört dass Kinder gegen
ihren Willen in Gemeinden festgehalten
und von Männern als selaven gehandelt
würden er behauptete er habe Frauen
gesehen mit gebrochenen Armen und
schraubenziehen und anderen Werkzeugen
in ihren Beinen zu Treffen kamen hatte
irgendeiner dieser Behauptungen
irgendeine Substanz Null keine überhaupt
keine ich habe den Mann mit dem Hut
Gregory Andrews um ein Interview gebeten
aber er hat
abgelehnt der Minister für indigene
Angelegenheiten malel BR sah sich die
Beweise an die das Programm über
sogenannte pädophilenringe vorgelegt
hatte und sagte Kindesmissbrauch in
unvorstellbarer Zahl vorkomme
außergewöhnlich sowas zu sagen oder
außergewöhnlich vor allem vor dem
Hintergrund dass er wusste dass der
anonyme Jugendarbeiter in der
Fernsehsendung sein Berater
war für mich war das ein Hinweis auf
einen völligen Mangel an gutem Glauben
bei der Produktion des
Programms denn wenn sie niemanden finden
konnten der objektiver war mussten die
Programmmacher doch zumindest denken
dass es ein mögliches Problem
mehr als nur ein mögliches Problem und
doch machten sie einfach
weiter die australische
kriminalkommission die Sie eingerichtet
und ihr besondere Befugnisse verliehen
haben fand keine Beweise die Northern
Territory Police fand keine Beweise
seitdem haben unzählige Berichte keine
Beweise gefunden ich zähle sie ihnen auf
wenn Sie möchten wenn Sie wollen
sachlich falsch was sie herausgefunden
haben war hat die australische
kriminalkommission also
hat sich
geirrt die Realität ist dass sie als sie
in diese Gemeinden gingen keine Leute
finden konnten die die Beweise
untermauern würden sie werden Ihnen
sagen dass es jede Menge
unausweichlicher Beweise gibt wie z.B
sexuell übertragbare Krankheiten bei
sehr kleinen Kindern und ich habe
persönlich mit Eltern und Verwandten
gesprochen die die Personen
identifizieren können aber Sie werden es
nicht
tun sie haben aborigin Gemeinschaften
und zwar alle Gemeinschaften nicht nur
mutjulu beschuldigt pädophilenringen
Unterschlupf zu
bieten zunächst einmal wurde ein
unabhängiger Bericht erstellt eine
Untersuchung erstellt von der
arbeitsregierung des Northern Territory
sie besuchten 45 verschiedene aborigin
Gemeinschaften im Northern Territory und
fanden in jeder einzelnen Gemeinde
Hinweise auf
Kindesmissbrauch hat den
Untersuchungsbericht völlig falsch
dargestellt und es auf sehr grobe Weise
für seine eigenen Zwecke genutzt warum
sollte der Minister so etwas sagen
wollen weil es einfach nicht wahr
ist ich verstehe es
nicht der Bericht wies nicht auf
Pädophile oder pädophilenringe hin oder
dutzende Menschen die umherstreifen und
Kinder irgendwie misshandeln es war
überhaupt kein Bericht dieser Art wir
haben geschrieben worüber uns die Leute
erzählt haben und welche sorgen sie
haben sie sprachen mit uns über Armut
sie sprachen mit uns über Kinder die
nicht zur Schule gehen junge Mütter
mangelnde Bildung für
alle
Wohnungsmangel
Arbeitslosigkeit wenn bestimmte
Bedingungen wie diese vorliegen ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es zu
Kindesmissbrauch kommt sehr
hoch die Vernachlässigung und der
Missbrauch von Kindern sind
unbestreitbar all die Fakten gingen
verloren die Aufgabe der Propaganda
durch die Fernsehprogramme bestand darin
eine Situation zu schaffen in der die
Regierung handeln konnte um diese
Gemeinschaften zu
kontrollieren sie haben in diesen
aborigin Gebieten ziemlich provokante
Schilder
aufgestellt würden Sie die gleichen
Schilder hier an der Sunshine Coast in
Queensland
anbringen würden sie diese Schilder an
Orten Anbringen an denen es zu
Kindesmissbrauch kommt Mittelklasse
Australien Arbeiterklasse Australien
weißes Australien das ist eine wirklich
gute Frage denn worauf sie eigentlich
Hinweisen ist dass wir nicht wegen der
Hautfarbe diskriminieren sollten sondern
wir sollten Kinder tatsächlich schützen
unabhängig davon wo Sie sich befinden
lassen Sie mich Ihnen sagen ich lebe
hier an der sunshinecast und es gibt
hier Kindesmissbrauch genau hier besteht
kein Zweifel an sexuellem
Kindesmissbrauch es ist kein
ausschließliches Recht einer bestimmten
ethnischen Zugehörigkeit oder eines
bestimmten
Ortes
also erstellte die Central Australian
group of specialists im Jahr 2008 einen
Bericht über die
Intervention und ich nehme an eines der
wichtigsten Dinge die wir herausfanden
und die wir der Regierung klar machen
wollten war dass bei den 11000
durchgeführten Gesundheitsuntersuchungen
nur bei einem Kind ein
Gesundheitszustand festgestellt wurde
über den vorher nichts bekannt war und
bei dem es sich nicht um einen Fall von
sexuellem Missbrauch
handelte wenn Mel brff diesen von
Experten verfassten Bericht also
zurückweisen wollte und seine
Mitarbeiter es versäumt haben vor Ort zu
arbeiten dann ist seine Zurückweisung
einfach
falsch warum erschien Gregory Andrews
anonym das ist ein Mann der praktisch
für sie gearbeitet hat warum erschien er
in der ABC lelin Sendung und nannte sich
selbst oder sie nannten ihn einen
anonymen Jugendarbeiter warum ist das
passiert
ich weiß nicht warum sie mir diese Frage
stellen denn ich hatte absolut hat er
sie vorher nicht informiert nein er hat
sie nicht informiert
nein die parlamentarischen
Aufzeichnungen erzählen eine andere
Geschichte BR hatte dem Parlament
mitgeteilt dass Gregory Andrews die
Informationen seinem Büro übermittelt
habe die Sendung verwendete doch
Filmmaterial das zeigt Kinder
benzinschnüffel
nicht das stimmt sie stammten nicht aus
die Aufnahmen des benzinschnüffel
stammten aus Docker River einer hte
Kilom entfernten Gemeinde aber es wurde
als mutul
dargestellt Mitglieder der Mulu
Community beschwerten sich beim ABC über
das
Programm eine Untersuchung bestätigte
dass das Filmmaterial das angeblich aus
Mulu stammte von woanders herkam
die Verkleidung eines Regierungsbeamten
als Jugendbetreuer wurde als bedauerlich
bezeichnet aber gerechtfertigt denn er
habe gesagt er fürchte um seine
Sicherheit die Beschwerde wurde
abgelehnt ABC lehnte mein Angebot ab für
diesen Film Interview zu
werden die Leute von majulu und andere
haben sich beim ABC beschwert und es
wurde eine Art interne Untersuchung
durchgeführt die dann das Programm
entlastete
wie beurteilen Sie den Prozess der das
Programm entlastet
hat das ist wirklich eine F es ist ein
bisschen so als würde die Polizei ihr
eigenes Verhalten untersuchen es mag
intern ein völlig angemessener Prozess
sein aber sich dann darauf zu verlassen
um die Programmmacher zu entlasten geht
doch etwas zu
weit haben sie eine Entschuldigung vom
ABC erhalten als das ans Licht
kam nein wir hatten keine Warnung ig
nichts und wir wurden hängen gelassen
als wären wir immer noch
schuldig eine der Tatsachen die die
Mitglieder der mudulo Gemeinschaft
traurig machte war das Versäumnis der
Medien zu erkennen dass die äußerst
reißerischen Anschuldigungen die gegen
sie erhoben worden waren falsch waren
und für falsch befunden wurden von der
australischen
kriminalkommission niemand hat sich
jemals die Zeit genommen den Namen und
den Ruf der M Gemeinschaft
Reinz ich sage es noch mal die
kriminalkommission der sie besondere
Befugnisse verliehen haben hat ermittelt
und keine Beweise gefunden das ist
einfach falsch Sunday age pädophilenring
Vorwürfe im Northern Territory
unbegründet er hat uns mit dem was er
getan hat völlig vernichtet dieser
Eingriff war vollkommen widerlich falsch
ich akzeptiere auf jeden Fall dass die
Intervention falsch und dumm war ich
habe es damals gesagt ich vertrete
diesen Standpunkt er basierte auf einer
Täuschung mehr als das es basierte auf
einer
Lüge was war die Lüge nun die Lüge war
im Grunde genommen dass alle Männer der
aborigin Kinderschänder
sein Männer sind meiner Meinung nach die
am meisten dämonisierten Menschen in
Australien und ma
denn das ist mein Vater das sind meine
ältesten das sind Männer mit denen ich
jeden Tag zu tun habe es macht mich
traurig dass sie als Vergewaltiger und
Menschen dargestellt werden die sich
nicht beherrschen können ich finde das
einfach absolut ekelhaft und es zeigt
dass diese Leute die diese Dinge
schreiben die aborigin Männer nicht
kennen sie haben offensichtlich nicht
viel Zeit mit ihnen verbracht und das
ist es was mich wirklich traurig macht
weil es auch Frauen betrifft denn das
sind unsere Ehemänner sind unsere Söhne
das sind unsere Onkel es ist wirklich
ekelhaft und ein Mythos es ist nicht
wahr ich meine wir hatten in der
Vergangenheit viele rassistische
Maßnahmen aber diese war die Mutter von
allen und um diese Politik auf den Weg
zu bringen hat die Regierung mit der
Unterstützung der Opposition damals der
labourpartei das
rassendiskriminierungsgesetz ausgesetzt
und es gibt nur einen Grund warum man
ein rassendiskriminierungsgesetz
aussetzt und zwar wenn man etwas
rassistisches tun will und beide
Parteien gaben zu dass es rassistisch
war die Vereinten Nationen haben es als
rassistisch gebrandmarkt aber sie haben
es trotzdem
getan ich bin mir sicher wenn z.B
Südafrika vorgeschlagen hätte dort eine
ähnliche Gesetzgebung einzuführen hätte
es im Rest der Welt absolute Empörung
gegeben und hier in Australien können
wir es tun und kommen damit durch und
niemand scheint zu glauben dass daran
irgendetwas nicht stimmt das ist der
Punkt den ich nicht
verstehe welchen Sinn hat es Ihnen so
etwas aufzuz
ich finde es extrem verdächtig ich
erinnere mich dass ich ein paar Jahre
vor der Intervention in
Zentralaustralien war wie riesige
Hubschrauber über unser Heimatland
flogen mit diesen gewaltigen ich weiß
nicht was es
war ich kann nur annehmen dass sie nach
Mineralien suchten und sie sind einfach
vorbeigeflogen es war als würde man sich
einen Science Fiction Film ansehen diese
Hubschrauber mit diesen großen massiven
antennenähnlichen Dingern die an ihnen
hängen und dann ein paar Jahre später
kommt die Regierung und bricht in die
motujulo Gemeinschaft ein um diese
pädophilenringe die es nicht gab
auszulöschen und dann führten sie die
Intervention durch erstaunlicherweise
fand man in Zentralaustralien große
Mengen an Uran und seltenen
Erden und das alles fällt ungefähr zur
gleichen Zeit zusammen und die Leute
denken vielleicht ich bin ein bisschen
paranoid aber man kann nicht anders als
paranoid zu sein wenn all diese Punkte
irgendwie
zusammenlaufen 2007 startete die
Regierung des Northern Territory eine
Kampagne namens top and secret
2 um nach neuen Mineralvorkommen zu
suchen laut einer Branchenumfrage ist
das Norn territory der neue Hotspot des
australischen
Bergbaus
es war hier in J Creek wo eine Reise für
mich endete und eine andere begann es
war
1969 meine Zeitung in London hatte mich
zurückgeschickt um mein eigenes Land zu
entdecken wie
ironisch es war ein Schock für
mich das war ein Foto das ich damals
gemacht habe
J Cre war das geheime
Australien ein staatliches Reservat in
dem die Menschen gezwungen waren unter
unvorstellbaren Bedingungen zu
[Musik]
leben das war eine Arrestzelle aus Orten
wie J Creek wurden Tausende von Kindern
von der Polizei und Sozialarbeitern
verschleppt
sie wurden als gestohlene Generation
[Musik]
bekannt die Politik war Assimilation sie
wurde von der eugenikbewegung
beeinflusst die Verbindungen zum
faschissmus hatte ein Beamter beschrieb
es als auszüchtung der
schwarzen es war
Völkermord
[Musik]
my BR SK by take
him between
hers I
heard
my
[Musik]
einige Abig Kinder wurden gesucht und
weiße Australia konnten sich das
aussuchen das ihnen gefiel wie das
kleine Mädchen auf diesem Foto markiert
mit einem
[Musik]
Kreuz
viele wurden Arbeitskräfte in Häusern
der
Mittelklasse ein nicht angemeldetes
System der
Sklavenarbeit Lorna Fu und ihre
Kindheitsfreunde versteckten sich aus
Angst weggebracht zu
werden ich sagte seid vorsichtig sie
nehmen ihren Müttern schwarzen Müttern
ihre Babys weg ich bin eine schwarze
Mutter also gingen wir immer hin und
bauten ein kleines Haus am Bach entlang
wir Gruben ein Loch und übten rannten
dorthin und legten uns hin ein aborigin
Junge er wurde Kakadu genannt er musste
aufpassen er musste uns mit Blättern der
Gummibäume
bedecken und tatsächlich kamen eines
Tages die Pferde im Galopp und wir
Randen hinunter und versteckten uns
dort wir versteckten uns in diesem Bach
und dieser aborigin Junge bedeckte uns
mit Blättern ob nichts passiert wäre und
sie ließen die Peitsche um ihn herum
knallen und er bekam Angst er geriet in
Panik er rannte zurück zum Lagerplatz
und die Sozialarbeiter fanden uns und
nahmen uns
mit und die Mütter schrien und weinten
und hielten sich am lastwagenfest als
sie uns
wegfuhren ihre Mutter muss so sie hat um
mich getrauert bis zu ihrem Tod haben
sie ihre Mutter sehr vermisst ja oh ja
ich habe fast jede Nacht geweint wir
hatten immer viel
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gekuschelt in dieses Gebäude bekannt als
der bungalo wurden in den 20er bis 50er
Jahren viele Kinder gebracht wo sie
leichte Beute für Sexualstraftäter
waren Australiens dunkelstes Geheimnis
ist das weiße schwarze Frauen und Kinder
vergeal
ell welch bittere Ironie wenn die
aborigin heute diese Geschichte den
falschen Behauptungen gegenüberstellen
die zu der Intervention geführt
haben jetzt ist es anit ein neues
Kapitel
aufschlägt eine neue Seite in der
Geschichte Australiens indem wir das
Unrecht der Vergangenheit wieder gut
machen und so mit Zuversicht in die
Zukunft blicken wir entschuldigen uns
für die Gesetze und Richtlinien
aufeinanderfolgender Parlamente und
Regierungen die diesen australischen
Landsleuten tiefen Kummer Leid und
Verlust zugefügt
haben es war keine Entschuldigung für
den Mord die Vergewaltigungen die
Vergiftung der australischen
Ureinwohner oder der First Nations wie
die Menschen heute lieber genannt
werden es war eine Entschuldigung dafür
dass man uns so viele unserer Kinder
gestohlen hat mit der Absicht sie zu
assimilieren und sicherzustellen dass es
in Australien keine Kontinuität der
traditionellen Praktiken der aborigies
gibt
her als Premierminister haben sie in
Australien ein langes Schweigen
gebrochen sie haben sich bei den
Aboriginies für den Diebstahl ihrer
Kinder
entschuldigt sie sagten und ich zitiere
es ist nicht das Gefühl das Geschichte
macht sondern unser Handeln was genau
meinten sie
damit ich glaube bei der Entschuldigung
waren zwei Dinge
notwendig eine davon war eine wenn man
so will zutiefst spirituelle oder
emotionale Transaktion zwischen
indigenen und nicht indigenen
australi und das war einfach aber
aufrichtig um Entschuldigung zu bitten
für manche mag es abgedroschen klingen
ich habe gehört dass es als
gestenpolitik beschrieben wurde aber
wenn sie einem Volk oder einer Person in
ihrem eigenen Leben schweres Unrecht
angetan haben können sie nicht anfangen
eine normale Beziehung zu führen bis sie
auf dieser Ebene das Unrecht in recht
verwandelt
haben aber das Unrecht ging weiter
innerhalb eines Jahres nach R
Entschuldigung wurden in der Stadt
Lightning Bridge in New South Wales 37
aborigin Kinder ihren Familien entrissen
angeblich wegen
Vernachlässigung
Tage alt sie gingen einfach ins
Krankenhaus und rissen ihn aus den Armen
seiner Mutter das ist unsere Geschichte
das ist es was mit den kleinen Kindern
der gestohlenen Generation gemacht
wurde im Rahmen einer dreijährigen
Kampagne der Familien in Lightning Ridge
kehrten fast alle ihre Kinder zurück
aber sie sind die glücklichen überall in
Australien werden schwarze Kinder aus
ihren Häusern verschleppt viele werden
den weien liefert und verlieren
jeglichen Kontakt zu ihren
Familien dies ist eine neue gestohlene
Generation es ist erst zwei Wochen her
dass ich einen Anruf von den
notgeratenen Gemeindemitgliedern erhielt
die sagten dass die Polizei und die
kinderschutzbehörde morgens am Haus
einer Familie aufgetaucht sein während
sie beim Frühstück saßen sie stürmten
hinein nahmen ein dreijähriges Kind
setzten es in ein Auto und fuhren 700 km
von dieser Gemeinde weg
die Großmutter die in diesem Haus war
heulte jagte dem Auto hinterher warf
Steine und konnte es nicht
glauben sie sagte immer wieder dass uns
das schon früher angetan wurde als die
gestohlene Generation ihren Höhepunkt
erreicht hatte das passiert wieder im
Norden von Queensland wurden fast 200
Babies im Krankenhaus von ihren Müttern
getrennt
oftmals werden diese Babys wenige
Stunden nach der Geburt vom
kinderschutzdienst entfernt keine
Erklärung über den Ablauf warum das
passiert ist welche Rechte sie haben wie
sie dagegen angehen können was sie
möglicherweise tun können weinend
zurückgelassen weinend um ihre
Kinder die Autorin dieses Berichts OL
wurde nach der Veröffentlichung von der
Regierung des
entlassen der Bericht enthüllte dass die
Regierung in einem Jahr fast 80
Millionen Dollar für die Überwachung und
Entfernung von Kindern ausgegeben hat
verglichen mit nur 500 000 für die
Unterstützung dieser veramten
Familien also 80 Millionen Dollar pro
Jahr für das was man Kinderschutz nennt
aber das sind die Leute die Kinder
wegnehmen das
stimmt sie nehmen Kinder weg wenn Sie
glauben dass es in der aberig Gemeinde
Kindesmissbrauch gibt ihr Bericht zeigt
aber dass im Northern Territory wo es
laut dem Minister unvorstellbar viele
Fälle von Kindesmissbrauch gibt die
Zahlen tatsächlich zu den niedrigsten in
Australien
zählen das ist richtig es ist ziemlich
ernüchternd das ist mehr als
ernüchternd das ist bei allem Respekt
ein riesiger
betrug in Gesprächen sagten mir die
Leute wie sehr sie ihre Entschuldigung
zu schätzen wussten aber fast alle
Männer und Frauen sagten dass ich nichts
geändert hätte tatsächlich sagten viele
von ihnen die Situation sei
schlimmer ich werde hier nicht aufstehen
und irgendeine Flagge schwenken und
sagen weißt du was es ist alles in
Ordnung wir haben es behoben das tue ich
nicht die großen australischen Propheten
zu zitieren ist
okay mir scheint dass die guten
Nachrichten auch in die Kategorie
Blödsinn fallen
könnten warum haben sie ich glaube
direkt nach der Entschuldigung gesagt
und sie haben das sehr nachdrücklich zum
Ausdruck gebracht ich möchte das ganz
offen sagen es wird keine Entschädigung
geben was die Frage der Entschädigung
für direkt erlittene Verletzungen
betrifft ich habe aber den gesag ich
parabordet nicht tu ich
nicht die Erwartungen der Aborigines
wurden wieder einmal erhöht aber was
folgte war Verrat das ist das ständige
Muster der schwarz-weißbeziehungen in
Australien sie erwecken diese
Erwartungen und missbrauchen dann dieses
Vertrauen durch
[Musik]
Verrat dieserat ist tief imchen leben
ben zu mchtig Interessen wie der
[Musik]
Bergbauindustrie der australische
Bergbausektor ist enorm
profitabel er macht einen Gewinn von
rund ein Milliarde Dollar pro Woche er
erwirtschaftet einen Gewinn von knapp 52
Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr das ist eine
riesige Menge Geld im Grunde genommen
sind es große Unternehmen die enorme
Gewinne mit Mineralien erzielen die sie
nicht gemacht haben auf Land das ihnen
nicht gehört und das nennt man Smart
economics das ist die australische
Wirtschaftsentwicklung des 21
jahrhunderts in den 80er Jahren
versprach die laborptei den aber
nationale
Landrechte sie nannten es Australien
größte moralische Angelegenheit mit
dieser Propaganda ging die bergbaulobby
zum Angriff über durch landansprüche der
Aboriginis könnte ihnen das Recht auf
Zugang zu bis zu 50% von Westaustralien
entzogen werden halten Sie es für fair
dass weniger als 3% unserer Bevölkerung
Besitz von bis zu 50% unseres Landes
beanspruchen sollte ganzseitige
Zeitungsanzeigen du dachtest es wäre
dein Zuhause den noch
mal abgezielt auf berühmte Orte in
Australien ein wunderschönes Bild von
einem wunderschönen Ort mochtest du das
hier schau jetzt genau hin deine Kinder
bekommen vielleicht keine Chance dazu
dieorigin werden es absperren weiße
Menschen werden dort nicht hingehen
können für den Besuch deines
lieblingsstrandes brauchst du eine
Genehmigung du kannst dort nicht mehr
schwimmen oder angeln weil die schwarzen
ihn
einnehmen es war aublich es war schlicht
grob und leider
effektiv nach ihrer Wahl gab die
Regierung von Bob Hawk nach die
allgemeinen Landrechte wurden
aufgegeben im Jahr 2010 gab die
Bergbauindustrie 22 Millionen Dollar für
eine Kampagne aus um eine geplante
Steuer auf ihre supergewinne zu
stoppen
was sagen alle die Westaustralien lieben
streicht die
[Applaus]
Steuer was sollten unsere
westaustralischen Zeitungen
sagen streicht die
Steuer die Kampagne war erfolgreich
Labor
premierministerinte dieuer aufast
null Verlust wird auf 60 Milliarden
Dollar
geschätzt genug um Landrechte zu
finanzieren und die Armut der aborigin
zu
beenden
das Volkes der nunga in Westaustralien
dessen Widerstand einer Geschichte der
Enteignung
trotzt hier spricht er kompromisslos zu
einem weißen
Publikum ich habe von meinen frühen
Schuljahren bis zu meinem
Erwachsenenalter dunklen Sarkasmus und
Rassismus seitens der Behörden erlebt
ich glaube nicht an Nationalismus er ist
beleidigend und vermittelt das falsche
Identitätsgefühl derjenigen die
Länderein gestohlen haben von denen sie
jetzt ben sie rechtmäßig
Erben robert hat diejenigen verfolgt die
die Aboriginies verunglfen und ausbeuten
in einem bemerkenswerten Heilzentrum in
Perth namens dumetang feiern Robert und
seine Frau Selina die Kultur und
Geschichte
der und hier kämpfen sie gegen eine
moderne Krankheit namens Selbstmord sie
haben auf diese Weise ihren eigenen Sohn
Bob verloren
wir haben hier in Perth in den letzten Z
Wochen 7 bis A Selbstmorde erlebt und
erlitten unter ihnen Kinder im Alter von
14 15
Jahren die Geschichte der
Kolonialisierung und was heute zu dieser
Epidemie geführt hat spiegelt die
Politik der Regierungen und vor allem
der gestohlenen Generationen
wieder sicherlich ist die fortgesetzte
Inhaftierung junger aborigin Männer ein
schlüssselfaktor und ich glaube bei
vielen jungen aborigin Männern spielt
der Verlust der Identität Kultur und
ihres Erbes eine
Schlüsselrolle in dem Sinne dass ihr
Selbstwertgefühl gemindert wird und ihr
Wert in einer Gesellschaft die ihre
Kultur nicht wertschätzt oder sogar sie
selbst als
Menschen viele unserer jungen Leute
sehen am Ende keine Hoffnung kein Licht
am Ende des tun oder Hoffnung in ihrer
Zukunft und so lautet die Antwort für
viele von ihnen nicht mehr hier sein zu
wollen Robert und Celina haben dies zu
einem Gedenkraum gemacht und ihn mit
Fotos von aber und ihren Familien
bedeckt die alle von einem verkürzten
Leben betroffen
sind alle Menschen die hierherkmen
besuchen uns um emotional ein Gefühl der
Verbundenheit Zugehörigkeit zu
spüren sie haben hier einen Ort an dem
sie buchstäblich weinen
können hier ist ein weiteres Foto von
unserem Enkel er ist ein sehr
temperamentvoller kleiner Junge er hat
seinen Vater vor vier Jahren durch
Selbstmord
verloren und dieser Raum hier ist ein
Denkmal eine Homage an seinen Vater
unseren einzigen Sohn es war als ob mit
dem Tod unseres Sohnes all unsere
Hoffnungen und Träume starben aber das
ist nicht der Fall denn hier ist unser
wunderschöner kleiner Junge und hier
sehen wir jetzt unsere Hoffnungen und
Träume mit unserem Enkel und den beiden
anderen Enkelkindern die wir
haben wir glauben dass wir wenn es an
der Zeit ist weiterzugehen zur Erde
zurückkehren und wieder Teil dieser Erde
werden so werden die Kreisläufe der
Menschheit und der Erde eins und wir
sind nicht getrennt
wenn Sie also ein Glaubenssystem haben
sagen wir mal ein westliches
Glaubenssystem werden sie außerhalb
dieser Welt an einem Ort namens Himmel
gerettet nun natürlich können Sie mit
diesem Land machen was sie möchten man
kann es plündern vergewaltigen und
zerstören es hat keine Konsequenzen aber
in unserer Kultur würden wir sehr hart
bestraft werden wenn wir dem Land
Schaden und es auf die Art und Weise
verletzen würden wie es heute
geschieht das weiße Australien hat kein
Zugehörigkeitsgefühl zu diesem Land es
hat nur ein Zugehörigkeitsgefühl zu den
Einrichtungen Institutionen und Städten
die hier aufgebaut werden es versteht
dieses Land
[Musik]
nicht stop
killing love one at
Christmas love one on
birday but SM won be
[Musik]
forgotten
never in anderen westlichen Ländern
leiden die Ureinwohner immer noch doch
im Gegensatz zu Australien wurden
historische Verträge unterzeichnet die
ihr Recht auf Selbstbestimmung
anerkennen Australien ist das einzige
entwickelte Land das wiederholt wegen
der Misshandlung seiner indigenen
Bevölkerung verurteilt wird hin und
wieder sprechen australische Regierungen
von Versöhnung einer akzeptablen Idee
nicht dazu beigetragen hat anständige
Häuser zu bauen oder die Blindheit bei
Kindern sowie Unterernährung und
dickenskrankheiten zu beseitigen es hat
nicht verhindert dass junge Menschen
Selbstmord begehen und es hat den
Landraub der vor mehr als zwei
Jahrhunderten begann nicht gestoppt wie
bei der Apartheit in Südafrika ist
Versöhnung ohne Gerechtigkeit nicht
möglich und dies wird nur geschehen wenn
den ersten australi ein echter Vertrag
angeboten wird der dieses reiche Land
seine Ressourcen und
der Nutzen wird dann gegenseitig sein
denn bis wir ihre Nationalität
zurückgeben können wir niemals unsere
eigene
[Musik]
beanspruchen
so the night was blessed with
evil the S began
the walking through the park at
midnight coastal town on
[Musik]
ears out the
BL on
[Musik]
the R up for
you for the
rest
[Musik]
g no more whispering in
mind no more whispering
in let R up to break these chains
stop
[Musik]
kill Miss for
theame when theyun for the black and
[Musik]
white
son of a
father child of a mother and a
[Musik]
friend s
and no more
[Musik]
Wh ing in our
heart let rise up to break these
CHS stop these
killing let rise up to break these
CHS stop
[Musik]
killing